un autre rendez-vous est à ne pas
manquer ce week-end le département des
Yvelines inaugure les rendez-vous de la
Madeleine ça se passe comme son nom
l'indique au château de la Madeleine au
cœur de la Vallée de Chevreuse au
programme 4 weekends sur la vie à
l'époque médiévale pour en parler avec
nous Joséphine Coleman berger alors ce
weekend ça commence avec le thème de
l'artisanat plusieurs animations et
ateliers sont au programme comme la
calligraphie et là broderie oui tout à
fait c'est-à-dire que ce lieu
emblématique puisque comme je l'évoquais
rapidement tout à l'heure c'est quand
même un lieu qui était un site fortifié
médiéval le plus beau de l'Île-de-France
et qui et qui a maintenu vraiment ce
côté médiéval sans réhabilitation et il
était important que l'on puisse attirer
aussi un public familial parce que c'est
le but quand même c'est de faire quelque
chose
d'intergénérationnel et donc on a choisi
de faire sur plusieurs weekends et bien
ce que l'on sait à peu près de du monde
médiéval et là vous l'avez dit
effectivement sur l'artisanat et bien on
va pouvoir aussi nous apprendre un petit
peu ce qui se faisait à l'époque et
c'est plutôt intéressant parce que les
enfants les adultes tout le monde va y
trouver quelque chose c'est un lieu très
important sur notre département que le
département vous savez en a fait
l'acquisition en 1981 et nous souhaitons
justement développer tout ça on a
quelques petites problématiques si je
peux me permettre c'est que c'est pas un
lieu qui peut accueillir énormément de
monde puisque il y a pas un parking
énorme mais par contre c'est un lieu
magique dans lequel aujourd'hui le
département a déjà fait pas mal de
travaux de réhabilitation et
d'investissement et nous nous faisons là
justement le mois d'avril le mois de mai
et puis aussi à l'automne nous allons
faire pas mal d'animations tours qui
tournent autour du monde médiéval avec
des costumes avec même des dégustations
donc je pense que ça va être intéressant
ce sera concrètement il y aura un vrai
village médiéval avec des stands on est
vraiment immergé dans dans
après les compagnies qui sont invitées
sont des compagnies qui ont cette
compétence et qui savent
particulièrement bien vous remettre dans
cette ambiance donc ce que l'on souhaite
à terme peut-être on demandera au
spectateur de venir aussi habiller de
cette façon-là ça pourrait raisonner ça
fait un peu de théâtre aussi donc ce
sont des compagnies théâtrales de toute
façon donc c'est vrai qu'on va essayer
d'immerger notre public le public autour
des comédiens dans ce monde-là ce serait
une bonne chose en tout cas justement ce
premier week-end il est animé par
l'association Les regrettiers d'histoire
il est enfin cette association est
spécialisée dans la reconstitution
historique c'est ça ils sont de même il
est amour et ils ont l'habitude de
fonctionner dans de cette façon là donc
pour nous ça pas été très compliqué de
les choisir parce qu'on savait qu'ils
avaient cette spécialité on espère
vraiment
attirer du monde je sais que ce château
est un château qui attire déjà parce que
il attire des personnes qui font des
trek qui se promènent dans toute notre
de Chevreuse et on a aussi énormément de
tourisme sur le département des Yvelines
puisque c'est en puissance depuis le
covid tout le monde s'est rendu compte
que les Yvelines c'est un poumon vert
dans lequel on peut vraiment venir à la
fois en balade à pied parce que on a des
forêts mais aussi à vélo et c'est vrai
que avoir des lieux comme ça comme des
maisons des illus c'est important donc
voilà les week-ends
puisque les premières découvertes que
nous avons pu avoir ce sont aussi des
découvertes qui datent du 12e siècle
puisqu'on a retrouvé des céramiques on a
retrouvé même un cadavre de chien c'est
pas pour être morbide mais c'est pour
vous dire que à l'époque il faisait
travailler aussi les chiens sur les
chantiers et on a aussi trouvé des
allez faire à chevaux à cheval les faire
à cheval c'est mieux voilà même une
gambarde on a trouvé vous voyez c'est à
dire que c'est un lieu qui nous amène
vraiment dans cette époque là et ce qui
ce qui est superbe c'est que il y a pas
eu de réhabilitation ni à la Renaissance
ni plus tard et ce qui fait qu'il est
resté vraiment dans son jus médiéval
donc c'est c'est intéressant vraiment de
venir nous on espère au niveau
départemental avec les réaménagements
que nous faisons sur les patrimoine et
la culture moi je m'occupe du Tourisme
et de la Culture au niveau du
département et bien on est une
association à la fois de réhabilitation
et d'activités culturelles pour pouvoir
faire venir du monde ça vous donne envie
d'y aller François Jolivet
tout à l'heure que le le théâtre
autour de l'an 1000 était avait
pu renaître à la faveur notamment de ce
que vous avez le drame liturgique qui
est puisque c'est la religion qui vers
l'an 1000 a réintroduit involontairement
entre le médiéval et le théâtre on est
pleinement on est pleinement lié euh
voilà et donc c'est intéressant et le
comité préalablement avait effectivement
investi ces lieux avec grand plaisir
mais là pour le mois de juin nous
concentrerons sur théâtre à la ferme qui
est une autre opération
ce qu'on a quatre fermes partenaires qui
vont nous accueillir dans des lieux où
combien différents et avec grand plaisir
et donc on va pouvoir lier les
nourritures terrestres avec les
nourritures spirituelles voilà je vous
pose aussi la question Véronique
perturbide bonsoir vous venez le soir
parce que vous allez nous présenter vos
informations insolites dans quelques
instants mais du coup vous aviez prévu
au départ de nous parler des rendez-vous
de la Madeleine dans vos informations
mais oui je suppose que ça vous donne
envie d'y aller mais complètement
surtout que ce que dit Madame c'est que
on a l'impression qu'on va on va y être
et on va dire directement plongée dans
le moyen-âge quoi pas de choses qui vont
polluer c'est c'est très intact
j'imagine et je crois que cette
compagnie des regretti récratives ça
voulait dire quelque chose mais je me
suis un peu trop quoi c'est pas les gens
qui qui ramassent terrestre de
nourriture et recratier
du Moyen-Âge exactement les restes des
tables des nobles ou je sais pas quoi
elle a été redistribuée ou revendue
voilà donc ça ce sera pour le premier
week-end qui aura lieu bah là le 22 et
le 23 avril et donc d'autres rendez-vous
sont à venir puisque à la fin du mois de
mai le thème ce sera sur la la médecine
en juin c'est les armures et les épées
qui sont souvent les hommes d'arbres et
puis en octobre le château sera envahi
par des Vikings exactement dans les
attentes pieds fermes
avec la compagnie du clan diva
association qui est basée à benicourt
benecourt donc tout ça ce sont des
associations qui ont vraiment une
spécificité importante donc si vous
aimez les batailles un peu virulentes et
un peu viriles
médicinales mais bien sûr des visites
j'imagine ça va être la surprise voilà
des filtres oui on va rajeunir et même
les plus grands en rôle occasion de
créer leur propre déodorant
mais c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans toutes ces activités live
vraiment c'est pas uniquement venir et
regarder c'est venir agir participer
être vraiment acteur
voilà mais la manifestation
c'est important et bien merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
si vous êtes intéressé les rendez-vous
de la Madeleine ça commence ce week-end
les 22 et 23 avril l'entrée est gratuite